le lundi on a l'impression qu'il est
proisraélien le mardi euh ah ben non
finalement euh il faut inesser le feu
donc on peut plus éradiquer le Hamas
alors du coup il est où il est où
Emmanuel Macron plus d'un mois après
l'embrasement du conflit entre Israël et
le Hamas le positionnement du président
de la République fait débat en cause une
périlleuse quête d'équilibre visant à
concilier le soutien à Israël le
maintien d'une position singulière de la
France au Proche Orient et la volonté
d'éviter l'importation du conflit sur le
territoire national le flottement
commence dès après l'attaque terroriste
du Hamas à la mi-octobre l'Élysée
affirmait que les conditions n'étaient
pas réunies pour une visite du président
français en Israël ce n'est qu'après ses
homologues américains allemands et
britanniques qu'Emmanuel Macron fait le
voyage pour s'aligner d'emblé avec la
Rost militaire lancé par l'État hébreu
le retour à la normalisation qui
s'annonçait ne seront garantis que si la
réponse d'Israël à la violence est
évidemment sécuritaire et implacable
face au groupes terroristes la France
est prête à ce que la coalition
internationale contre DAEs puisse lutter
aussi contre le Hamas une initiative
hasardeuse qui n'aura pas fait long feu
tant les perceptions du conflit diverg
entre Israël et la plupart des pays
arabes mais déjà la prise de position
d'Emmanuel Macron avait semé le trouble
dans le corps diplomatique français une
note commune rédigé par une dizaine
d'ambassadeurs au Moyen-Orient aurait
été adressé au k d'Orsa regrettant le
virage Atif du président français en
faveur d'Israël bientôt le sort des
civils palestiniens dans la bande de
Gaza qui suscite une indignation
croissante à l'international pousse le
président de la République à infléchir
son discours et au malheur des
Israéliens s'ajoute désormais celui des
Palestiniens et nous ne pouvons pas nous
y résoudre parce que toutes les vies se
valent et parce qu'il n'y a pas de
double standard la semaine dernière
Emmanuel Macron durcit encore le ton
jusqu'à se démarquer de l'ensemble de
ses alliés
occidentaux une question se pose alors
comment reconnaître à l'État hébreu le
droit de riposter et d'éradiquer le
Hamas tout en appelant à un cesser le
feu qui profiterait à l'organisation
terroriste côté israélien c'est
l'incompréhension qui domine le Premier
ministre Benjamin netanahou dénonce une
erreur factuelle et morale une
incompréhension qui gagne désormais
l'Hexagone où l'absence remarquée du
président français à la marche contre
l'antisémitisme fut interprété comme un
énième en même temps visant à se
soustraire à une prise de position
claire moi ce qui me frappe c'est que je
trouve que ce conflit est un ultime
révélateur je dirais des des fractures
françaises une partie de de
l'immigration de culture musulmane en
France a beaucoup de mal à à à condamner
la violence
islamiste cont terrorist qui nous menac
tous